Going down?
Yeah.
You live in the building?
(elevator ding)
Yeah.
They keep making
'em bigger every year.
Buildings.
(elevator ding)
You grew up
around here?
I was born here.
Oh, you were born here,
in the elevator?
Kidding, it's my New York
sarcastic sense of humor.
(dinging)
Looks like we
caught the local.
And what about you--
You doing all right?
Everything all
right?
Uh-huh.
Life.
Yeah, I'm fine,
thank you.
I'm fine, too.
I just need my first
cup of coffee,
then I'm
a little better.
Not good for you, it's
not that bad for you.
Like red wine.
They say you have
a glass of red wine
and it's good for
your heart.
This week went by
fast, didn't it?
I mean, it's
already Thursday.
I was telling somebody
yesterday, I go,
"What is it, Tuesday--"
They go, "No, Wednesday."
I go, "Shut up."
They go, "Look."
I looked, you know, and it was
Wednesday, they were right,
but, yeah, you know,
you gotta enjoy--
We got a couple of days
left so we can enjoy those,
that's for sure.
So how you doing,
all right?
Mm-hmm, fine.
Me too, but rents keep going
up, paycheck stays the same.
Give me a break, right?
Ah, you got your health,
that's what matters.
(repeated dinging)
What--
Is this the elevator
going to hell?
No.
Sorry.
This is hell.
(Satanic music)
Hot enough for you?
It's a dry heat,
I'll say that.
I don't
mind the heat.
You know what gets me--
The humidity.
Seen the news
lately-- A lot going on.